this is Startalk hi I'm Neil deGrasse
Tyson I'm an astrophysicist with the
American Museum of Natural History and
I'm host of Startalk radio welcome back
to Startalk radio and fighting all these
air molecules like what's up with that
we win astrophysicist my favorite part I
thought it was really poignant when she
teared up recognizing her mortality and
enough tier collected in the eye so that
one of the drops floated off of her face
I thought that was a heavy hammer there
but they did some actual experiments
with tears on the space station and the
surface tension of the liquid actually
will more likely have it stay connected
to your cheek surface tension is what
will allow a drop of water to come down
here and not just fall off it'll sort of
come horizontally a little bit maybe
even to your chin the water is clinging
to a surface that's surface tension it
overrides gravity at those levels so we
saw the tier we got it but I thought
that that was poignant a great scene
with the fire extinguisher ways to
propel yourself in space how terrifying
it was that the broken particles of the
satellites coming at such speed that's
scary stuff by the way the total
satellite destruction scenario it's real
one satellite can take out 10 they each
take out another 10 go from one to 10
two hundred to a thousand in a matter of
days you could maybe a month total
satellite destruction if you go around
smashing satellites don't do it Oh
another thing by the way
Sandra Bullock randomly comes out of
orbit and she lands in a pond and just
swims to shore excuse me most places on
earth you'll land you are near no shore
at all you're gonna drop in the middle
of the Pacific or in the Arctic and
you'll be eaten by sharks in the ocean
or polar bear will eat you RT something
bad is gonna happen to you you're not
going to just crawl out and sit on land
and say boy I had a I had a long day you
know I got in big trouble when I send
out some tweets about gravity I just
thought people would be interested to
know what they didn't get right in fact
I didn't even say they got it wrong I
just said these were mysteries of the
movie why is it that Sandra Bullock a
medical doctor is repairing the Hubble
Space Telescope excuse me we don't send
medical doctors to repair the Hubble
Space Telescope anymore then we're going
to send a mechanical engineer to do
open-heart surgery on you please get so
I tweeted that and they might have had a
little emotional flavor to it but still
what I didn't tweet were the hundred
things that got right I celebrate the
movie for its effort to get so much
right it's unfortunate that my initial
salvo of tweets were interpreted as me
somehow not liking the movie I enjoyed
the movie immensely
you